hi everyone I'm just gonna avoid that  for one second I just want to say it's  very humbling to be here and to hear all  you guys speak I once was a young  renegade filmmaker and I really take my  hats off to anybody who's out there  making films in that way or as a student  or as a young person because very  clearly they dress better they have  better hair than than the last  generation do they speak better but they  have their eyes on what's really going  on and they're not thinking about the  money and I love that and thank you so  it's beautiful to hear all you guys talk  now as obviously an exotic foreigner I'm  a shoo-in to present the best foreign  narrative film there may be subtitles  for some of you thank you mom and you  know some of my favorite films of any  award season other foreign films so I'm  very honored to present this award and  here are the Award winners